Judging from the e-mails I've been getting
from many of you, it sounds like much of my
audience agrees with me that it feels as though
American democracy is in peril.
It's a sort of precarious state right now,
hanging on the brink with a president openly
saying the election is rigged, that the correct
result would be that he wins and that if he
doesn't win preemptively, he's saying it will
have been fraud and he will not necessarily
leave the White House peacefully.
So it's natural.
It's common.
It's logical to be feeling despair and helplessness.
Right now, Donald Trump and his cronies have
gotten away with everything with so much.
And our old friend John Nichols at The Nation
wrote a really great piece about the Bernie
Sanders toolkit for defending against Donald
Trump's threats to democracy.
Bernie Sanders actually spoke at George Washington
University last week and went through what
must happen.
And I think this is useful both to understand
the nuts and bolts, but also just to have
some hope, some hope.
So here are the ideas.
Bernie's plan to defend democracy.
Number one, establish a nonpartisan commission
to oversee the election.
Now, the devil is always in the details with
these nonpartisan commissions.
But but that is the idea have by far the largest
voter turnout in American history.
Bernie and I, 110 percent aligned on this.
I've been saying for months now, whatever
the reality is going to be about voter suppression,
whatever else the biggest ever turnout is
the starting point to trying to remove Donald
Trump.
People should vote as early as possible, says
Bernie.
Absolutely.
The earlier you vote either through in-person
early voting or vote by mail or hand delivering
your absentee ballot, the earlier the better.
All state legislatures must allow mail in
ballots to be counted before Election Day.
This is key.
32 states already allow this.
Some don't.
If we can get a jump on counting mail in ballots,
we reduce the threat of the scenario in which
Donald Trump is slightly ahead in some key
states on Election Day and use his lawyers
to stop or slow down the counting of as yet
uncounted absentee ballots.
The more ballots that are counted early, the
better off we are.
News media should clarify, says Bernie.
There is no longer a single election day.
It's important that media also explain to
people you can vote now in many states.
Early voting has started in many states.
Mail in voting has started in many states,
and that it is not just about November 3rd
anymore.
Social media companies must stop disinformation
from being spread on their platforms.
We have a blockbuster story from Channel four
in the UK about Donald Trump's targeted deterrents
of black voters in 2016.
And a big piece of that is social media.
And it is also on the social media companies
to stop disinformation.
And there should be both congressional in
DC and state hearings and state legislatures
to explain how the election will be handled
in the event of all of these various scenarios.
Now, not all of these ideas are Bernie's original
ideas.
The nonpartizan commission, for example, was
the idea of former director of now national
intelligence, Dan Coats.
The ACLU has been putting forth a lot of these
ideas, etc..
But the point is, there are things to do now
not waiting until later.
If we wait.
We lose.
Biden needs an army of lawyers ready to go
now, not on November 4th.
We learned last week that at least some lawyers,
the DNC and the Biden campaign have at the
ready.
Those lawyers need to not just be ostensibly
The lawyers need to know now, not later.
What are the different strategies that Donald
Trump's lawyers might use to swing the election
to him?
The time is now, not later.
We're at a structural disadvantage here.
If we are playing defense and they are playing
offense, they only need one strategy we haven't
thought of.
They might have six strategies.
If we defend against five, they've got number
six.
So there is a difficulty implicit in playing
defense in this way.
But the time is now to think about it.
Not not later.
So get your absentee ballot.
If that's your plan, you can go to vote, dawg.
Slash absentee hyphen ballot.
Very important vote, dawg.
Forward slash absentee hyphen.
That's the dash ballot.
You can also just Google vote, dawg.
Absentee ballot.
It'll be the first link that comes up and
we are linking to that Web site in the description
to the YouTube video.
I tracked my.
Yesterday here in Massachusetts, it's currently
pending, it shows that my primary ballot was,
of course, received.
They voted absentee in the primary.
They haven't been sent out yet.
Most states have tracking systems.
Vote, dawg.
Org tell you exactly how to register in any
state in which you live.
Very, very important.
Bernie has a plan.
We need plans.
We need strategy.
We can't wait until 11 p.m. on November 3rd
when the Trump lawyers get ready to petition
courts to stop the counting of absentee ballots.
We wait until then, we're done.
So that's why it's so important to move on
this right now.
And there we can all do something, even if
it's just having a plan that increases the
likelihood of your vote being tallied correctly.
That's a plan.
That's something we can do.
Yes, you can.
Phone bank.
Yes, you can volunteer to be a poll worker,
so on and so forth